here's a quote from Laurence Olivier
that reminds me of your work I'm not God
I'm not kidding I came upon this quote
and I thought this really sounds like
your work so it's a quote that that
Olivier wrote and said that an actor
should be going for the jugular he
should be like a lion a leopard but also
a serpent now to that I say that sounds
like your characters in high-rise in the
night manager which just had an amazing
finale last night on the BBC absolutely
it sounds like Hank Williams it sounds
like Henry v it sounds like Loki the god
who would be king of us all I'm
wondering if when you're preparing for a
role if you're thinking does this one go
for the jugular or should I let this one
wash over me as you're approaching it
which approach do you like if I let
anything wash over me my life would be
much easier um I don't I can't explain
it I tend to I tend to go for the
jugular every time can everyone hear me
first of all it was that great just the
first you know theatrical acoustics
stage train I I don't know how to do it
any other way
actually and I don't know that I bought
I don't know that I've ever been able to
to do anything III say it as a syllabus
I'm aware that it can be a strength but
it can also be a weakness because the
focus is obsessive and and so when I go
for something I go for it at the expense
of everything else and I I love what I
do simply and I I feel so lucky that I'm
allowed to do it and that I did get to
do it for a living and I'm cinema and
theater have had such a profound effect
on me in my life and and so I always
every time a new script or a new role
comes along I am motivated by the
thought that I will I won't forgive
myself if I don't give it everything
and but I do try to choose different
kinds of things because I'm interested
in in the diversity of people and though
and the complexity of people and the
multiplicity we contain within it so I
really think the thing that unites us
all in the world is that we are
constantly in constant and that
inconstancy in that contradiction is
something that I've always tried to
explore with my characters because I
think we do we do things that the
contrary contradicts ourselves all the
time there's a the Walt Whitman poem the
song of myself' I am large I contain
multitudes I contradict myself and sorry
I'm digressing but yes jugular every
time we've had the pleasure of sitting
the last few nights talking about I saw
the light which we'll talk about more in
depth in a little bit but something you
said really struck me which was at about
10 years ago you had the realization
that life is not a dress rehearsal that
this was really this is time to kind of
get serious I'm wondering what it was
that preceded that epiphany and how it's
a bird you on wow I think I had I've
been very diligent in my training and
tried to listen to the advice of all my
teachers and instructors as as a student
as an academic as a training actor and I
always wanted to do right by them and I
found myself is a very scary moment when
you're a young actor most people find
themselves in their early 20s and
everything is possible and nothing is
guaranteed and you start auditioning and
you if you're lucky enough you have an
agent and you start auditioning and they
send you everything from period drama to
casualty to Dairy Milk commercials yep I
went up for a Dairy Milk commercial when
I was
and and you are thrown into the business
and thrown into it at the deep end and
there's no time for doubt or failure
except routinely that's what happens to
all of us and I was so I perhaps was too
careful in auditioning and I would
always get close to to landing roles and
to booking jobs and I would never quite
get there and it's it's a I mean that
this is a universal experience for all
creative people certainly actors is that
the constant rejection at the beginning
and you had to get used to it and you
have to get thick-skinned about it and I
was so exhausted by I was I trying to
sort of because at first you take it
very personally and I thought well no
one's like no one's gonna no one's going
to help me get that the only person who
could do this is me and I started
preparing in a different way and and I
sort of stepped up to the plate a little
better I think because I could feel time
sliding away and and I wasn't getting on
with life I just was sort of stuck in
this rut of neither acting nor doing
anything else and the experience of
being in your twenties is so energetic
and I felt so stagnant actually so I
just kind of changed everything up and
and it worked I'm lucky now at about
that time you work a CEO in a fellow
with Giotto lagea for and Ewan McGregor
and you play dual roles in Cymbeline you
got the Olivier Award for your stage
work for Best Newcomer at that point did
you suddenly think oh I may get
everything I hoped for and were you kind
of fearful of what would come next
actually that was the moment I remember
I was coming off a tour of Cymbeline for
cheek-by-jowl the theatre company and we
toured all over the world but she came
here in in May of 2007 right down right
back
meow and they've been to Moscow and
Paris and wreak havoc and Milan and
Frankfurt and and then be later did a
stint at the Barbican and he finished in
Madrid and I remember I would done six
months of touring this show and I was so
tired and I all I wanted to do was just
chill and my agent called me said he got
an audition for a fellow next week you
know they go okay but I knew he said
Michael Grandage is directing it
Chua tell Ejiofor was playing Othello
you and McGregor is playing Iago and
Kelly Reilly is playing Desdemona and
I'd read this play at a level English
and I reread it and I knew for some
reason it for the first time how to play
Cassio and I didn't want to leave
anything to chance
so I just learnt the entire part before
the audition and my audition took 10
minutes and Michael Grandage still
remembers that audition he said you came
in because I knew that everyone was
going up for that it was such an amazing
opportunity and Othello it was it was a
real moment as a very happy time it was
a great production principally because
of chouet l was so magnificent in the in
the title role and he led from the front
and so many fortuitous things happened
as a result of that production I
remember this we were all quite ready
very rarely we were we felt very ready
to go to open on art the day of our
dress rehearsal and we had the show was
ready to go with the last thing we need
really actually needed an audience at
that point and Michael Grandage
said to the company would you mind if I
opened the house to people in their
final year at drama school so third year
students from Rada from lambda from
central from from the Drama Centre and
we were like no not at all and it was a
sort of nice way of saying free tickets
because they couldn't probably working
to get tickets and then he said you mind
if I ask my a friend of mine
called kenneth branagh to come and see
it and so we all went okay you know like
the most sort of probably the man who's
had the greatest impact on the playing
of shakespeare of his generation and he
knew michael grandage because michael
before taking over the Donmar Warehouse
had directed can in Richard the third at
the Sheffield crucible Abbey won't be a
short you're fine yeah absolutely
no worries and remember so Kenneth
Branagh came to the dress rehearsal and
he really enjoyed it and the next
morning I received a phone call from my
London agent saying um Ken is doing a
radio play for the BBC of Cyrano de
Bergerac and he's played Cyrano and he
would like you to play Christian and so
that's how I met Ken and then the
following year Tom Stoppard also came to
see a fellow and he had written and the
adaptation of Chekhov's Vaughn off to be
directed by Michael Grandage
in which Kenneth Branagh was starring
and they all turned to me and said you
have to play the doctor so I was like
okay and at the same time the BBC's
carthan director it's time with the
script for Wallander and I remember
embarrassingly in bashfully a meeting
can Branagh at the de costume fitting
and he said so I'm calling this my
Hiddleston year
and I just thought well don't [ __ ] it up
basically mercifully I didn't so and
then and then we became firm friends and
and and that was and he invited me to
audition for Thor and it was a very open
net they were casting they both that
Marvel wanted young actors to play the
principal roles who had no previous
attachment in the audience's mine and I
got cast as Loki and that was really
that was my foot in the door so to speak
I just love that your connection with
Branagh expands both stage and radio and
TV because of Wallander and then film
it's like the only thing you guys didn't
do together was like The Telegraph that
you're like you know that you guys hit
every every possible medium and is that
story true about how you grab the water
bottle as it went you had heard that
Branagh was was directing Thor you
wanted as to as your fake prop hammer
and went up there and said you know
think of me as Thor's that's true story
we live in a world that is ruled by the
Marvel Universe now and and there was a
time when they made one film and it was
Iron Man and so we were all in in during
the theatrical run of even off in the
West End it was very exciting we were
just as a company we were very excited
on behalf of on his behalf that he had
managed to land this huge directing gig
which none of us knew about and somebody
told me Jeana Vicki who I had most of my
scenes with was playing his wife and she
told me that Ken had got this huge
directing gig and so as this the
Chekhovian doctor in that play I had
longer hair and a goatee and wire-rimmed
spectacles and a pocket watch and you
know it looked like a very Slavic
Russian doctor from the 19th century I
as a joke in the interval I picked up
this empty water cooler and run up to
Ken's dressing him and pretended to be
swinging Thor's hammer it's probably
ill-advised but I did it anyway
and and then actually that's when he
said well actually don't joke there's a
couple of good parts in there
so yeah that's I came about well we're
very lucky that you didn't get there and
you got loki because really it i think
that the key to so much of whether it's
brits richard the third or is any sort
of a the villain needs to be somebody
that is playful and devious and you find
so many rich layers of new odds within
loki what was the key to him for you to
that character well i can and i kind of
used Shakespearean villains as a
touchstone it was a very red like quite
a Shakespearean script and the journey
of thor actually was very similar to the
journey of prince how in the Henry the
fourth and never the third of the
trilogy which obviously he knew very
well having played how the never the
fifth many times and and so Thor goes
from a hot-headed impetuous young prince
into being a into being worthy of of his
title and similarly we tried to think
about the the immaculate and terrifying
talent for improvisation that's account
two like Iago has someone who can think
on his feet and manipulate every
situation to his advantage we talked
about Casius in Julius Caesar who is
characterized as having a lean and
hungry look we talked about the brothers
in King Lear Edmund and Edgar Edgar
being the favored son of Gloucester and
Edmund being the bastard son who is
driven by some sort of terrible lack of
self-esteem to take his father and his
brother down so those seemed to be
interesting aspects to steal from
Shakespeare really and then I just have
to remind myself I was playing the god
of mischief which is a hell of a thing
to be god of actually you know
there's gods of war and thunder and
justice and and this guy was the god of
mischief so I I knew I had to have as
much fun as possible you know the devil
plays all the best tunes and it became
that became a cocktail and weirdly from
those beginnings he he just emerged he
emerged in costume fittings he emerged
as I dyed my hair black and I have read
the first script and I thought there was
a fascinating in inside this
extraordinary lavish visual effects spec
you know action spectacular there was a
very simple human drama about a father
and two sons and so on that that bran
had talked to us about - Anthony Hopkins
and and Chris Hemsworth and myself it
was a real we really worked on that that
inside you know rainbow bridges and
journeys through space and time that
there was actually something people
could latch on to that was human and
real it's amazing watching that scene
back by the way I haven't seen that so
it seems like a long time ago one of the
great things that that hold up about it
though is that obviously the best the
best villains don't think of themselves
as villains I mentioned Richard the
third a couple mins ago he thinks he's
doing the right thing you know and in
the Marvel Universe as well it's the
same type of dynamic to them they're not
the villain they're the one who's just
have a different point of view and the
one that everybody should listen to
right but every villain is a hero in his
own mind
and I really latched on to that you know
someone who's actually trying to do the
right thing it just makes bad choices
even in Avengers he's still trying to
make him make the right choice possible
exception of taking over the world with
his photo fascistic tendency yeah I
still it's funny I haven't played him
for three years but I still have a soft
spot for him I still kind of yet I was
gonna ask if a lot of people who have a
lot of actors who have a connection to a
character like that sometimes when they
come around again
you're something oh they almost think of
him as if he's like another guy like oh
that gets nice he's gonna be coming
around again a nice guest in the house
is gonna be Loki he's gonna be coming
around you kind of have that feeling
that he's sort of like this other guy at
this other point yeah it's so odd
because you never so rare as an actor to
have a chance to go back to a character
sometimes you know especially you create
a character and you hope that he makes
an impact or people find a connection
people can recognize something in him
that's entertaining or truthful and you
never very rarely dude get a chance to
go back and I've gone back to him a
couple of times and it is odd it's like
hello darkness my old friend you know
yeah we'll see we'll see
nothing ends in the Marvel Universe you
mentioned the holocron which is amazing
the BBC production with the hollow crown
which is so beautiful your approach to
parental becomes Henry v what was your
approach to Henry v I think that
performance and that particular
production is so beautiful and so
exquisite what was your approach to
henry v yeah he's a fascinating time III
the hardest thing about that challenge
was doing Henry and/or house journey in
Reverse because of the because of the
schedule of Simon Russell Beale who
played Falstaff and we had to shoot
Henry v first and then shoot Henry the
fourth and actually we because of our
locations we ended up shooting the end
of Henry the fifth at the very beginning
and I kind of I played the character in
reverse order so by the end the very
last scenes are shot in a 15-week
engagement were
when Prince how ilysm is it his youngest
and most immature and playful in the in
the tavern with Falstaff but I'd already
I'd already done the Crispin's Day
speech I'd already done once more unto
the breach dear friends and that was
interesting just it's the s theatre
differs from film as you always shoot
films out of sequence as I'm sure you
all know but but sometime buddy were the
part as complex as that not to have
experienced the beginning before I got
to the middle of the end was fascinating
and and it was an interesting time it
was with Richard Eyre directed Henry for
Part one and two and Thea Sharrock
directed and with the fifth and we
decided that they had to speak to our
own even though it was part of a
tetralogy that was was produced by Sam
Mendes and being broadcast on the BBC as
a celebration of British culture in
conjunction with the 2012 Olympics we
felt that Henry the fifth is is a play
about war overwhelmingly if you read it
again it is a meditation on the
spiritual cost of warfare and
responsibility and and an Henry as a as
a general in a way a leader of his army
as well as a king is the most
interesting psychological aspects of
that play are about the the toll on his
soul or and the guilt and the shame and
and you know there's a fantastic
soliloquy upon the King let us our
hearts our lives lay on the king we must
bear all and it we decided that rather
than it being a kind of rousing
endorsement of warfare as as actually
Olivier Olivier edited out some of the
more brutal aspects of that he cut out
the speech of Henry before the French
before the castle of Harfleur went where
henry v has some
horrible things he says we're gonna your
father's taken by their silver beard and
their motor Reverend heads dashed to the
walls you're naked infants spitted upon
pikes
he's these are all things he's
threatening to do unless they open the
gates and it's it's Marshall and it's
ugly and Olivier in forty-five
necessarily cut those speeches from the
play so that it would be a more of a
galvanizing and rousing emotional appeal
to to everybody which the country needed
and we felt the you and I that we had to
reinvention to the plays really quite
balanced debate about warfare and that
in the way we shot it as well we
discussed that we lived in but we had a
very limited budget but when we lived in
a world in the wake of films like Saving
Private Ryan and gladiator and and films
like that changed the way audiences
relate to action and action sequences is
that people now demanded more verite in
their action sequences they wanted to
get up close to be able to feel the
intensity of the action and so we tried
to shoot the the battle sequences in a
different way but I loved playing it I
mean the the privilege of saying those
words on the film is very rare and and I
love doing it it's a great experience
you mentioned darkness a couple of
minutes ago are you have a talent for
that for a sort of a rule weary
morbidity a heaviness obviously in
addition to Loki there's only lovers
left alive which I love there's crimson
peak you actually do have a very funny
talent for comedy though I frankly I
love I love your Midnight in Paris
you're f scott Fitzgerald and actually
if anybody ever saw those Loki comedy
central bits that you did in preparation
for the dark world where you're dealing
with a quartet of children just as
formidable as the Avengers um you do
have a tell would you like to do more
comedy which lets do more like love to
do more comedy
really worth yes over something I've
been asking to do for a while I keep
telling everybody who you know when I'm
working up I've got a couple of agents
who so scare through scripts and new
material to send to me and they always
will send me the darkest time in really
dark so I would like guys come on
romantic comedy that's hilarious that's
what I was up for but yeah I've loved I
love doing comedy you know there's a
little bit of comedy a sort of
surrealist comedy and high-rise and
there are funny bits in in I saw the
light but that's what started for me as
a child you know I just like I I was if
I was ever exhibitionist it was in the
aim of making people laugh you know it
was it was pratfalls and falling off
chairs and there's nothing like getting
it getting a laugh actually so yes more
comedy please yeah do you remember your
first the first production that you saw
live stage production that you saw as a
child I was taken I was taken to see
pantomime so that was probably the first
Christmas time and my grandfather my
mother's father had a wonderful
tradition of gathering up his brood you
know with all the troops all of his
children and all of his children's
children at Christmas time to go and
watch something and I remember seeing
the Wind in the Willows at the National
Theatre I think Ian McKellen played
badger
I think a my phone maybe maybe he play
he was definitely Captain Hook and Peter
Pan and then I remember very clearly my
first Shakespeare production was a
Midsummer Night's Dream at the Barbican
Royal Shakespeare Company production
directed by Adrian noble with Alex
Jennings as Oberon and it was so it was
so joyful and so fun and I didn't know
the story the first time I had my head
sort of blown clean away in the theatre
was a production by Richard Eyre of John
Gabriel Balkman
the Ibsen play with Paul Scofield and
Vanessa Redgrave and Eileen Atkins and I
remember I was taken to see it by an
English teacher and it was the Littleton
theatre at the National in London and in
the interval he caught lead there were a
couple of us there and he called the
society said you never saw a live a you
never saw keel good he never saw
Richardson you are watching Paul
Scofield one of the greatest actors of
all time in what will be his last
performance treasure it and it was
magnificent I mean it was there was
something people still don't really feel
they worth close to Scofield and or that
they understood his talent and how he
pulled out what he pulled out but I was
aware I was in the presence of greatness
and it was a film about a family in pain
and Vanessa Redgrave was so good and I
in Atkins as well and that was one of
those life-changing moments where I felt
the power of dramatic storytelling to
unite a group of strangers you know I
was in the National Theater with all
these grown-ups and and and it seemed
when we sat down at 7:30 like a social
occasion and by 10:30 we all left bonded
by a common experience I really
understood this sort of that the power
that the theater and Cinemark and I
along those lines one of the reasons you
did deep Lucy the Terrence Avis Holmes
which I love is that it was an
opportunity for you to do something
about love at a time that you're doing a
lot of sort of things with a lot of
fighting in a lot of either violent
stuff either on stage or on screen and
it was opportunity to sort of explored
the idea of love what did you what did
you learn from that production and going
into it that Terrence Davies film I
loved making the deep blue sea um I
loved working with Rachel of ice
she's such a an instinctive warm actor
she's so generous and so compassionate
so human and for both of us it was a
story about a woman who was trapped
between two men neither of whom could
give her what she needed so you know her
first husband
it was kind and considerate but but
without passion and Freddy page I was
playing a by a former bomber pilot was
full of passion but without the
sophistication or the constancy and I
always read that as you know he just he
was one of those guys in in the Battle
of Britain who was who was so he was
given definition by his courage and by
the experiences of being a pilot and
after the war didn't know how to
readjust and so he actually you know as
Terence Davis said to me you can't put
an entire nation in therapy and that he
was basically self-medicating going to
the pub every night and singing and
drinking and and and therefore couldn't
couldn't meet Rachael's character Hester
at the level she wanted so actually it's
a tragedy of a love triangle where
everybody needs love from the other that
can't be requested and it was a
fascinating thing to explore because
that's so Terence as well anyone he
knows Terence Davis's work he feels that
so powerfully the loneliness of that
feeling and we shot it in something like
in something like twenty-one days in
London very quick very small but it's
amazing you get bonded by those
experiences I saw Rachel recently and
had seen it for a long time and I feel
like I've know her for the rest of my
life just by the intensity of that
experience speaking of the intensity of
the experience you have prepared for I
saw the light it was about four years
ago was about the time that this project
started first gestating right what
appeals to you about Hank Williams
because this performance in this film is
so spectacular and it and it hits all
these levels and all this nuance about a
man's life who a lot of us know the
music you may not know the story behind
all that what appealed to you about Hank
Williams honestly um when I first heard
the script it the the foreignness of it
was part of the thrill and I was born in
London in 1981 and Hank Williams was
born in Mount Olive Alabama in 1923
and he was a huge star and and changed
the face of American music and and part
of the excitement of it was the foreign
territory and as I spoke with a director
Mark Abraham lighting change
Budi start sliding into darkness he will
be here for a few more hours she's
changing the vibe yes I had a Skype
conversation with Mark Abraham and he
was most interested in taking the icon
off the pedestal in getting behind the
myth to play the man and Danny Dale who
was an old bandmate of of Hanks and the
drifting Cowboys used to say
legends don't know their legends when
they're being made they just folks and I
loved that and I wanted to I thought I
saw the light as a screenplay was two
films really it was portrait of the
artist as a young man and and a portrait
of a marriage and and Mark's conjecture
is that the power of those songs and
they they're the enduring legacy that
they transmit is connected to the
turbulence of his relationships with
women and he was you know he was so
young he was 24 25 when he had his first
hit and he was 29 when he died and he
did so much in such a short space of
time and he was from the south he lived
a hard life he was poor he had nobody
around him to anchor him he was
rebellious he was he didn't take any
[ __ ] and and he wrote about things that
happened to him in his life about
falling in love about falling out of
love about being in the doghouse and and
people connected to that authenticity in
that sincerity in a very profound way
and he changed music that's what I found
so amazing is you know I remember
listening to honky tonk women by the
Rolling Stones when I was 15
I had no idea what a honky-tonk was I
just thought it sounded cool and and and
and you know Mick Jagger and those guys
were were listening to Hank and
listening to honky-tonk blues and so was
Bob Dylan and so was Johnny Cash so it's
Bruce Springsteen they all start with
Hank whenever they whenever they talk
about their influences they go well all
starts with Hank Williamson and so that
the idea that I might be able to to try
and represent that was about a knife the
thing I found fascinating about Hank I
should say is the tension between his
external charisma and his internal
vulnerability he was clearly
electrifying on stage I mean that's what
people say that this presence he was
like Elvis before Elvis um but he was
tortured he was a tortured soul and he
was an addict he was an alcoholic he was
on prescription grow drugs he was
afflicted with spina bifida and this
tension I found that's what excites me
about acting really is it and some
people have noticed it that I I would
maybe with all my characters I try to
get underneath the the skin or behind
the carapace because I think as human
beings we construct an identity which we
present to the world and we all put our
best foot forward because that's who we
are but some but so often behind that is
a much more turbulent much more chaotic
vulnerability which we hide we hide it
with charm and with status and with a
sense of style and with detachment but
we're also vulnerable and and I think if
acting has any power it's to show that
vulnerability and that's what connects
people and not necessarily and what I've
done but I know that's what moves me and
the actors I admire is that they they
are able to show something very
Universal and fragile about the human
spirit behind a character
be they soldiers be their rockstars be
their demigods is that we're all bound
by our fertility and you even had to
additionally learn how to sing I mean at
they didn't couldn't sing earlier but
it's I couldn't saying I couldn't say ah
ha ha that's for the half big because
you learn how to sing the end yodel in a
Hank Williams style of yodeling and that
was an immersive process in and of
itself right yeah
becomes a time in a man's life when he
is called upon to yodel for some that
happens later than others for me happen
when I was 33 years old yeah it was him
it was for me it was essential I
couldn't see some people have asked me
why didn't i lip-sync along with Hank
and for me there would have been a break
in my authenticity and my interpretation
[ __ ] Spacek sang as Loretta Lynn in
Coal Miner's Daughter Joaquin Phoenix
sang as Johnny Cash and bought the line
if I was going to dress up and look like
Hank and and speakers Hank and interpret
his truth step into his shoes I had to
sing and I the first the bet the best
thing I did was just to get out of my
comfort zone in a real way and I moved
to Nashville for five weeks before I
started shooting I lived with this man
called Rodney Crowell our executive
music producer terrific patient and
respected musician in his own right
who'd seen Hank on his father's
shoulders at the age of 2 it was his
first memory and he went to behind boot
camp and we sang and played every day
and it was terrifying and difficult and
joyful and like anything you have to
dyspraxia practice
and I'd always said to him if I were
playing an Olympic sprinter I would need
a coach to tell me how many miles a day
to run and how fast and in that respect
I needed him to tell me how many miles
how many hours a day to sing and in what
way and we sang the blues and we sang
Howlin wolf and Jimmy Reed
we sang John Lennon we'd sit there we
talked about performance we talked about
the Freddie Mercury and Elvis and James
Brown these people who had this presence
you know what was this thing that unites
cat you know what is charisma on stage
Merle Kilgore who was one of the
drifting Cowboys said when Hank yodeled
especially in his first hit in lovesick
blues he said dad's when they stood up
and started throwing the babies in the
air it was a clearly this this this
extraordinary kind of sexual connection
he had with his audience it was you know
it was that Elvis moment so yeah
yodeling was pretty pretty scary but I
managed to pull it off a side note about
Hank that I feel I feel it in your
performance which is that he was one of
the if not the first musician of cádiz
catastrophic effect on his own life who
died of his own hand people forget about
George Gershwin died of a disease Benny
Goodman dies in a plane crash but Hank
Williams when he dies it dies because of
his alcoholism he's really the first one
I feel like we feel that in your
performance that sense of almost
inevitability yeah right so to me it's
so sad because there's an interesting
debate to be had as great art at what
cost especially in music and you think
of the number of extraordinary musicians
who have given us something very intense
and then have left the building and and
and and have left us too soon they're
stars that burned twice as bright and
not for long Jim Morrison Amy Winehouse
Janis Joplin Jimi Hendrix so there are
the that you know there are actors as
Heath Ledger's Marilyn Monroe James Dean
and and Hank was really the first of his
kind who who seemed to create at such a
velocity and such a pitch of intensity
that this this the amount of material
and and that came out of him during 1947
and 1953 which then went on to change
music and then he just he left us too
soon and there's a question as you know
as to whether is that are those self
destructive in its thinks part of the
generation of the art are they necessary
in some awful tragic way or is it is it
just that they're somehow they are
corollary to the to the art you know is
that what is the reversion of Hanks life
if somebody got him to help him at a
particular time might he have creatives
new work in his seniority that we now
don't have but I did find it fascinating
that he just he was unstoppable he was
on he was he was his presence was so
full in his songs and in his life and
that's what he's sang about and I think
you know the darker the circumstances of
his life the more powerful those lyrics
to write a song like cold cold hard is
it someone who's deeply lonely and which
is so sad because he was so successful
and so famous and there's an interesting
question about the isolation of Fame
especially at that time and what and
what in the corrosive aspects of it if
you're not if you don't have the armor
to protect yourself just by the way that
speaking about the accent your accent as
Hank is spot-on you just dipped into
another one a couple of minutes ago the
couple of nights ago I heard you do
Anthony Hopkins you have a great talent
for imitation and for you have a great
ear for for accents is that something
you've always had
I don't know I something I've always
done I've always I remember I had a
double tape deck recorder when I was
about nine and I used to do my own radio
show for an audience of one
and I would at the top middle to show
and I would do all the voices I would do
the news in the weather and I was so
fascinated I just I loved I loved doing
voices I always have actually I've
always done impressions and it comes
from love that comes out of you know and
it's something that's I guess that
musical it is an aspect I suppose a
musical ear and well the Anthony Hopkins
thing is is it's faster I mean you saw
that clip in up domine
I may I may have told the story before
but it was an amazing moment that's
worth recounting and I felt Chris
Hemsworth a knife that's so lucky to be
in Thor we were you know picked out of
obscurity son and suddenly standing next
to him and and Rene Russo and Natalie
Portman and colum Theo and idris elba
and we we follow we'd won the lottery
and Tony as he insists on being called
invited me to just have breakfast with
him before shooting ended and and he
said this extraordinary thing he said
said I see what you're doing I see what
you're doing it's interesting I've been
there before myself I see it and he said
you know my whole life I've been I've
played I played lots of different parts
I played kings and princes and warriors
and Butler's and poets and and people
stopping the street they asked me about
one man who do you think that man is I
knew who that man was and you know who
that man is
and and he said it's so fascinating to
me because because people want their
lives to be full of love and and and
laughter and friendship and and
happiness and they want to have good
lives at one time nice lights want to be
happy but what they really want is they
want to go into a dark room on a Friday
night with their friends and family oh
that loved one they want to sit in the
darkness and they want to look at
artists who are brave enough to stare
into that darkness and they don't have
to take it home
and I was so I thought it was such an
extraordinary summation of a certain
kind of work in music and film and at
the time the Dark Knight and Heath
Ledger's performance was it was very
current the time he shot that film and I
remember thinking you know that they the
intensity of admiration towards that
film in towards his performance is is we
all loved watching it but there's no way
you'd want to meet that person you
wouldn't want that person anywhere near
your life and yet we need actors and
musicians and writers and and painters
who are courageous enough to go there
and Hank was one of those guys who
almost who go to that dark place on our
behalf and and send dispatches back and
I found that very moving honest I think
that's absolutely true of Sir Anthony
Hopkins I think he's done that many many
times so I just anyway that's my Anthony
Hopkins story it's a great story and a
great accent that goes along with it um
speaking about tonal changes the the
effect of hi-rise I think it feels very
much like it's a tone that Stanley
Kubrick would like it's a satirical
absurdist tones from a JG Ballard novel
from the 70s on people really have to
see it to appreciate it I won't even do
it justice by describing it but in
getting into the absurdity of the
situations in SIA saw it in Toronto to a
rapturous response what was it like kind
of getting into that world of that sort
of absurdist satirical but hyper odd and
realistic tone I again it felt like new
territory I loved I loved been
Wheatley's films I don't know how many
people here have seen been Wheatley's
films and if they are the dark and I bet
that British - and I remember I saw a
field in England I was in and I was in
America I think you know and I and I
watched it when it was released it was
released across all platforms at the
same time and I watched it on my laptop
and it made me homesick I really there's
something
very sort of British about been his
sense of humor his inheritance of
British culture and I think I was very
important to me to champion British film
and I've the script came to me and it's
an adaptation of the ballad novel and in
Ballad there is there is provocation
laced into that novel he knew exactly
what he was doing he that the novel
opens with the line later as Lang sat on
the balcony eating the dog he reflected
on the unusual events that had taken
place within this huge apartment
building during the previous three
months and and he takes the English
middle-class essentially or the
upper-middle class
throws them into a building which is is
a sort of replacement for nature which
will provide for all their needs locks
the doors and keeps them there and
watches the the veneer of civilized
British manors fall away to reveal
something much more on on unpleasant and
it's a satire on on social mores it's a
investigation of class struggle it's an
investigation of inequality and and
Britishness really and I think Ballard
always felt outside British culture in
lots of ways is it you know someone who
grew up as a British citizen in Shanghai
but had never seen British soil until he
was a teenager he arrived and didn't
understand he arrived in the 50s after
the war and didn't recognize the place
he'd been brought up to believe in and
he couldn't believe this these little
disputes that that the heat that people
had about territory and and manners and
and so high rises a very provocative
satire on that and I enjoyed kind of and
I think we all did actually because it's
a film about indulgence and these are
other sophisticated characters I play a
physiologist who's trying to live in an
anonymous life in his 1000th share of
the cliff face but the building is
populated by very genteel professions by
dentists and Gynaecologists broadcasters
people in PR architects documentary
makers they will have very respectable
jobs and slowly as the as the
electricity goes off and the lift
stopped working and the water is turned
off you some darker more feral truth
about these people is revealed and
Ballard is really is really provoking
the audience and I think and been
honored that provocation in his film and
it is a mad chaotic dissent in a way
that that is a much more familiar if
people are familiar with the films of of
Kubrick perhaps or Lindsay Anderson or
Ken Russell or Nicolas Roeg it's it's
those a there's a big heroes for been
and and they became part of the fabric
of high-rise you've said you love diving
sort of into other people's lives
examining the other characters that are
going on I would love to talk about the
night manager and talk about Jonathan
pine that particular character obviously
a man who has sort of left a clandestine
life behind to be an anonymous hotel
manager and then is drawn back into it
what would appeal to you about Jonathan
pine and the night manager well first of
all the night manager is a novel by John
Licari and Licari is I think the one of
the greatest English novelists of the
last century I think he is a master at
his chosen form which is the espionage
thriller and I also think he's one of
the great analysts of the British psyche
and the the contradictions therein and
and that's what the novel is about as
much as anything
story-wise Jonathan pine is a former
British officer in the Army or soldier
rather
and who served in our adaptation in the
Iraq war of 2003 and you meet him in
2011 as the night manager of a five-star
hotel in Cairo in the middle of the Arab
Spring riots the popular uprising that
fell Hosny Mubarak and in the wake of a
particular incident he is recruited by
the SIS The Secret Intelligence Service
mi6 to become a field agent and take
down an international arms dealer who is
selling standard and chemical weapons to
the highest bidder in the Middle East
with no moral qualms about the victims
of the violence from which he profits
and the astonishing thing about the
night manager is is first of all it was
an incredible character a character
which which he's described in the novel
as a collector of other people's
languages a perpetual escapee from
emotional entanglement a self exiled
creature of the night and a sailor
without a destination and and and that
death is given a destination by his
moral commitment and you can feel david
korn well which is the real image on the
carry you can feel the support of the
author behind the moral courage of pine
and burr in this case played by Olivia
Colman and his his righteous rage about
against Hugh Laurie's character
Hugh Laurie plays a critical Richard
Roeper who is who has all of Hugh's
attributes he is charming and affable
and sophisticated and urbane and he want
to be in his company you want he want to
get to know him because you're drawn to
him he's attractive he's seductive he's
witty and and that sophistication is
very appealing and the way the brilliant
way that Hugh plays it is is that you
see why everybody loves Roper but then
you see
but underneath that is somebody who is a
psychotic and a cynic Hubal who believes
deeply in in the rottenness of the world
and that someone has to capitalize on
that rottenness for the greatest
financial gain so he trades in chemical
weapons he trades in death and he laughs
about it and and somehow Licari Zanger
is very very is very intense I remember
talking to him about it and that's why I
think in that scene that's the scene
with Olivia is it that line of pines is
lifted straight from the novel when Burr
asks pine why did he do it why are you
here talking to me and pine says if
there is a man selling a private Arsenal
to an Egyptian crook in the middle of
the Arab Spring and he's English and
you're English you do it some some
calling that that Licari is fury that
the inheritor of all the freedoms of
British society is using those freedoms
and privileges to do the worst things
imaginable to turn our world into a
darker place and I found that more in
them and the morality in it apart from
the the thrill of playing the
cat-and-mouse game that he is so expert
at constructing moving and and romantic
as that he's at you know the Carrey's
novels are full of flawed heroes who are
haunted by doubt haunted by moral
ambivalence about the DMV the hypocrisy
of having to do very bad things for the
greater good but there's a deep romance
in in their solitude and that's for you
note from Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy or
the spy who came in from the cold or the
constant gardener these are people who
were driven by a desire to to fight the
system and it was it was just a
wonderful thing to be part of
so I can go on I'm I will three more
question I will wrap up how long how
long Luke do you want us to go on for
okay we could be here if I honestly
could I have nowhere to be so I can go
on and I'm enjoying it so I will use
this I will some of you guys are all
still up for it I just want to comment
that the night manager has been a
phenomenon in the UK it starts in the
United States April 19th
it is your first spy I would this is
really just a shameless opportunity to
ask you about James Bond and if of
course given the chance to be James Bond
what would you bring to Mr Bond
that we haven't seen before I had to be
asked I couldn't possibly comment I
think it would be ungracious to to talk
I'm and I haven't been asked so I I
don't I wouldn't I don't want to talk
about I mean I wouldn't want to comment
on it and with that if I ever were the
case it's been called the greatest pub
game in in the UK right as people say at
the vine
thank you very much yeah I'll leave it
there but just then I will play off of
the idea of the preparation for I saw
the light and how much you know the
other night we were talking about that
you and one of your co-stars in I saw
the light wrench MIT we're talking about
the work of a philosopher Alain de
Botton in talking about there the
relationship between Hank and her
character and obviously you're bringing
up so many things in in preparation for
a role
are there any roles that you've had the
least amount of preparation for but it
actually benefited you what have you had
the least prep time for but you were
actually able to jump in and have it
work out for the best
I think f scott Fitzgerald at midnight
in Paris
I was cast very shortly before I was due
to shoot and Woody Allen in his unique
inevitable way didn't want me to read
the whole script he only sent the whole
script Owen Wilson every other actor in
that film received little piecemeal
stuff and so and I had to work out was
very cryptic I've got these pages and
the characters names in the scenes were
Scott and Zelda and Ernest and Gill and
I thought it does not in fact a
coincidence or is that Fitzgerald and so
it wasn't a comedic made explicit and I
wasn't quite sure if I was being asked
to play V F scott Fitzgerald and I
couldn't get woody on the phone so I
just sort of winged it because I was in
Paris about a week later and so I did as
much homework as I could on on his
speaking voice and and and I went back
and and read some short stories and read
some of Hemingway's accounts of
Fitzgerald but honestly the and he
shoots a short day because he wants to
play the saxophone and the clarinet I
mean oh and have dinner and and and so I
so really remember Corey Stoll with both
Hemingway I said whether I write he said
he basically got to take Senor out and
so yeah I remember just not really being
prepared I felt to play Fitzgerald but
it all turned out okay in the end it
sure did it's a terrific performance I'm
gonna wrap up with this question which
is that David far who did the adaptation
of the night manager so that one of the
things he loves about your portrayal of
Jonathan pine is that as an actor you
really listen and you turn silence into
a virtue is that one of the keys for you
for acting is really listening and sort
of being there and big present yeah and
it's so interesting a lot of people talk
about acting as being in the moment
being present and having the discipline
to to stay present and I actually
sometimes think that it's not quite that
it's actually about because sometimes if
you're in the present moment you at the
present moment is it's Friday night the
sun's going down you're losing the light
the crew attired
and you have to take yourself out of the
present moment and commit to another
moment which is fueled by your
imagination which I always think is
interesting because because sometimes it
is it's about having the discipline to
not be in the present moment and then
once you've isolated the scene that
you're in to really be there with your
scene partner and I do think the best
the best acting I've ever done has been
in response to another actor it's been
about the rally that we play together
across the net and that's when it that's
when acting is the most exciting when
you all do our very solitary homework in
our research and finally you get on the
you get on set you get on the ice you
get on the court and you play and and
that's you know the stuff that you very
generously showed before this is you
know if there's anything interesting and
what I'm doing it's because I'm I'm an
acting opposite Anthony Hopkins or
Olivia Colman or was at a scene I was in
the bathroom as it seen from her eyes
with Siena and Luke Edmunds Elisabeth
Moss right and it was great in that film
and Elizabeth Olsen in in I saw the
light and the fascinating thing about
pine was I think there is something very
active in the way that he is passive and
the whole portrayal felt like a kind of
a distillation of all my thoughts about
acting and identity is is actually
Jonathan pine himself is an immaculate
performer he's somebody who is able to
hide behind different masks he's able to
read to read the signs and the
atmosphere and adapt himself to any
given situation but always watchful
always listening and I and the
fascinating thing about the performance
was I was trying to communicate
how active his passivity is that there
are more energetic people in the room
whether it's Roper or Corki has
brilliantly played by tom hollander or
jed or anybody else that the pine is
receding into the shadows but I needed
the audience to see that I was still
listening that I was still watching that
in a way I'm I'm the avatar for them for
the audience in those things but yes in
some acting is the best acting is
reacting and listening and that's the
hardest thing to do we've been so lucky
to have you present with your to us
tonight ladies and gentlemen
I'm Hiddleston it's a great thing to
have rehearsals and just know that
you're you're coming at it from the same
point of view
it just means you can be more free you
can play and enjoy it and I think that's
what elevates good work - great work or
really exciting or daring work I've been
really lucky um and yet still it does
feel like it's really hard it's what we
are in a trade in which so many people
in the world want to do it it's
something that we everyone who does it
is passionate about
you